long been our waterways big dirty secret
tons of filthy water often sewage pumped
into rivers and seas whitstable in Kent
is no exception
it's why Jean and her friends have been
avoiding it
this is their first dip in six months I
bring my grandchildren down here in the
summer and I know I'm not sure whether
they should be allowed in the water or
not because you never quite know do you
and it's it's a worry with young kids
[Applause]
now there's a 10 billion pound pledge to
clean up our sewers and this admission
it should have been solved years ago I'm
here on behalf of the water industry to
say sorry sorry for the spills of
untreated sewage that have gone into our
rivers and onto our beaches and to say
today we get it we've listened we've
heard we understand the public upset of
anger that has been about this issue and
we have a plan to put it right
a plan that will see shareholders make
an initial investment but then
eventually will be passed on to
customers since 2010 water companies
have paid over 20 billion pounds to
their shareholders according to the
University of Greenwich and last year
there were more than 389
000 spills across Britain which
campaigners say we shouldn't have to pay
for it's just so enormously frustrating
when you see that they're taking a
billion pounds plus a year in dividends
and the CEOs are getting paid 25 million
pounds a year and then we're being told
well if you want this issue fixed you're
gonna have to pay again but we've
already paid for it once is it fair it's
not fair at all
well this is the voice of purification
Center where all the oysters are
actually should be purified in the
Oyster capital of the UK business owners
like Graham depend on the water quality
but he stopped relying on the ones on
his doorstep instead spending 1200
pounds a week to get them from elsewhere
I've gone to jerseys because I can
guarantee that if I sell this to
restaurant I'm not gonna have any
comebacks they will sell this to a
restaurant they're not going to have any
issues whereas whereas have I use the
local water
I do not know what contaminants are in
it
this the price of keeping his reputation
intact
the water companies wanting to fix
theirs the cost will be far steeper
Ashley harinax Sky News in whitstable